one thing I love in cinema that
Christopher Nolan does is he'll take
these opening images that have one
meaning and then when you watch the film
a second time they have a second meaning
Patrick you've been a filmmaker for 15
years yeah was it everything you thought
it would be
well you know there's lots of sides to
that question
um
no one ever goes in expecting the amount
of stress that comes with it but I think
the reason that is is because people
Overlook the idea of management
when you go in to make your own movie as
a director you're managing all the
personalities on set so you're managing
everybody's going to come into this and
I think we have a Fantastical idea of
what that would look like directing a
movie and the reality of it is you
really got to decide if you're going to
put the camera here or a half inch there
and everything has to be shifted one way
or the other
so and so with that said uh it's
completely different than what I
expected but there's nothing else in the
world that keeps my interest like all
the different levels of making a film
as far as like riding and shooting and
editing and how different all of those
are from one another
was it easier
I should say is it easier or more
difficult than you anticipated
making movies well
on April 23 2006 that was the day I
devoted my life to cinema I told a
friend of mine a dream I had and he
responded with you should make movies
and something clicked in my head and at
that particular time I was skateboarding
a lot and got it going into sponsored
skateboarder route
and so when I first started making
movies for the first five or six years I
only viewed it like skateboarding like
taking people sneaking into a location
filming something and then running away
and I would make these films and show my
family members them every holiday but I
didn't know about film festivals I
didn't know about
it could be a living or anything of that
sort I feel like throughout the time
you're making stuff you start to hear
these little nuggets of oh that's pretty
good or all of this and it kind of
builds into something
so
in terms of of
what I thought it was going to be making
films I think the big changing block for
me was realizing that it is a viable
option to make a career out of and
kind of crazy that the road I was on LED
that path that's
because I was making all these things
that just were
I don't know I had no idea what it was
and then suddenly it became something
where you can make movies and then I
learned what the budgets were and that
they could be millions and that's
strange
but you had said earlier that the the
managing people or whatever and that
that is such a big part of of anything
in in film
um
did you did you realize it would be uh
maybe
harder uh that you know because people
are sensitive actors are sensitive crew
members are sensitive maybe they don't
give that off when you first meet them
but you know people we all have our
little space and we bump up against each
other and and you know things will
happen on set and and maybe we don't you
know it's a little pressure cooker as
we've had a former guest say yeah it was
a great analogy did you think it would
be easy to manage people did you think
oh we'll all just we're all creating art
man this is going to be cool No One's
Gonna have any issue here well here's
here's the issue with where I'm coming
from with it I I've been wearing so many
hats on all these movies that when I'm
in the middle of the process
the managing of of people's expectations
and their time
I think when they see me running full
speed drenched in sweat everybody's like
follow him let's go and so I haven't had
a lot of moments where I've had to worry
about how people were viewing it because
again I'm from Cincinnati Ohio
so in Cincinnati I think the the the the
neighborhood that I was making films and
a lot of people had fun doing it
together and so that passion and fun why
we made these pictures
um I think it translates later to
hopefully now when I'm bringing people
together here and people are getting
paid that maybe there's a different
feeling because it doesn't really change
as you're making things I feel like the
kind of bubble you build in the
beginning
continues to be that bubble except for
sometimes when money is entered into the
picture there's a little bit more
pressure
and ultimately the person at the top
sets the tone and you seem upbeat to me
so they say you know forgive my analogy
here but things roll downhill we'll
clean it up a little bit so if if it's
positive then whatever rolls down will
be of a good thing you know filmmaking
taught me to be incredibly positive and
here's the kind of stuff that I bounced
off of for instance I was making my
first feature length movie but at that
time I didn't even know what a
feature-length movie was I just decided
I was going to take one actor and just
work with them over a long period of
time to make something long
in the middle of that I was supposed to
use a gas station bathroom
and I had about six or seven people
waiting for me crew members some actors
outside in the parking lot I walked in
and talked to the manager and the
manager's like no you can't use this
bathroom anymore and instead of going to
tell a single person about it I ran
across the street to a different gas
station and then secured this other
bathroom
and then came back and said we're going
over here and no one ever knew the issue
happened and so I I think a huge part of
this
is
obviously we all know it's problem
solving but falling in love with problem
solving that's to me what filmmaking is
you know really like embracing that
there is going to be something that's
not going to go right
and get excited by it and I think so
over the years especially making movies
with no money because I made two
features and a bunch of other shorts
with no no financing behind them except
for less pain for gas and food
um you have to be incredibly creative
and and to get those projects done so
then when the money enters the picture
in my mind I am hoping you can still
stay in the realm of we're making this
piece of art but then also understanding
you're also making product
and people need to get their money back
or you're not going to keep doing this
so it is a kind of transformation into
your vision and the color red or blue or
how the poster should appeal to the eye
but I love working with poster designers
so
that's all fun I like that though so so
basically if you had a bumper sticker
would be I love problem solving in terms
of for making movies because that's
basically what it's going to become like
Murphy's Law if a locations set it'll
there could be a chance it'll fall out
an actor might not show think different
things could happen 100 I I really
believe the theoretical idea that if you
point the camera at a subject long
enough something is going to transpire
when I first was making films
or like just adventuring the
juxtaposition of images in the editorial
I would go down the street corner on
Clifton Avenue and Ludlow in Cincinnati
Ohio and I'd set my camera up and I'd
film for 30 or 40 minutes just the
street corner and cars and people going
I'd go home and I'd watch it
just kind of curious is there some kind
of poetry in certain moments and there
really are there really are in movement
and
I I really think what we love about
videos and Cinema
and all of it together is it's a time
capsule for the human body if you look
at Jack Nicholson from the very
beginning of his movies all the way up
to present you've got this human being
and for him specifically it's a time
capsule of his emotions because they're
all a diary entry I'm sure he remembers
when he watches something exactly what
was going on at that time
so it's interesting because there's so
much going on in cinema in that way and
you know the theoretical idea of one
plus one equals three
where one image is cut with another
image creates a whole different image in
the human psyche that's happening
regardless if you understand it or not
so trying to embrace that notion is is
quite exciting
were you almost trying to recreate
slacker in some way you know that just
walking down the street and the
different interactions or that had
nothing to do with it that had nothing
to do with filming the street corner
that was just me wondering you know I at
that particular time I was reading a
book on directing and they were talking
about directing background actors and
and background stuff and I just kind of
started thinking to myself well it
doesn't take much time for me to go film
the street corner for 30 minutes like I
wonder what that looks like and that's
like the most realistic depiction you're
ever gonna get of a street corner and so
that's what that was but I was in the
neighborhood in Clifton I was known as
the guy making film so I could I would
carry my camera I had a Canon XL2 in the
beginning and I'll carry it around on my
tripod and I'd go into the U.S Bank they
let me film a scene right without paying
for anything I've not been shutting down
the institution they just let me set up
my camera and film but that's because I
just ran around and filmed all the time
again that was just my favorite pastime
was filming and making things and then
it obviously it just keeps getting
bigger you keep saying to yourself well
now I did this what if I what what could
I do next you know
so you caught these different moments on
film and I know you have a um I don't
know if this is one you caught on film
but you were at a restaurant and you saw
what you thought was a loving mother and
daughter together and it turned out
it wasn't that oh no no no no no no no
no no I know what you're referring here
for for Willis Peach the idea of behind
that I was driving in a car by myself
down down down the road from buying some
movies and I was just contemplating
stories and characters and out of
nowhere I said to myself
well are you coming or aren't you
and instantly I just knew it was a
mother saying it to a daughter in my
head but I knew that that wasn't really
her mother and that she was taking this
child but in my head I saw this classic
image of the angry mother like come on
let's go
and so we we went into that path of
making that movie but so you so how one
scene you could see you think it's just
a regular interaction and it turns out
it's it's much more darker in nature
hopefully you know
one thing I love in cinema like
Christopher Nolan does is he'll take
these opening images that have one
meaning and then when you watch the film
a second time they have a second meaning
and a lot of his images have these dual
meanings in them
and his belief
if I'm not mistaken from what I've
understood watching some of his
interviews and stuff of that sort is
um
that creates re-watch value the more the
more you embody in the picture different
layers of what something could mean
then the more that picture I think could
you know give an audience member a lot
to look at multiple viewings and that's
what we always get from from his movies
Christopher Knowles movies so then the
question lies how do you do that and I
think that just is prepping the script
going over it a thousand times thinking
about you know if you're writing the
screenplay what you know what what story
are you telling and from what point of
view and
yeah and and and how do images even work
with the mind because at the end of the
day that's what we're choosing every
time you choose a lens versus camera
placement
like if I wanted you to feel vulnerable
maybe I'd put the camera on a very wide
angle lens and put the lens camera right
up against your face and have you do the
scene and it might make you feel more
vulnerable at that moment or if I want
you to feel more secure maybe I put the
camera on a very long lens like the
safety brothers and uncut gems when
they're filming Adam Sandler getting
knocked into the fountain from across a
block on a 800 millimeter lens and Adam
has no idea where they're shooting
filming from so I feel like all of those
choices are uh
so important to making the piece but